aircraft waterborne wildfires which have
so far burned almost 4 000 hectares in
the Spanish island of Tenerife it's
affected thousands of people who've had
to leave their homes or stay indoors to
avoid inhaling the fumes
Spain civil guard has been moving door
to door to help evacuate hamlets and
villages in the affected area
some residents say they were given just
an hour to pack
it is super stressful we have to leave
our houses and everything but let's see
if we are lucky and hope the Fire
doesn't roll down the hill which would
be most dangerous let's have hope in the
firefighters
the fires have calmed down overnight
earlier a change in the wind direction
threatened to spread the Flames to new
areas firefighters struggled to keep the
blaze reaching populated areas Spain has
suffered drought for the past few years
it slept across tender dry fueling
wildfires in mountainous areas
the European forest fire information
system says Blazers burned 800 000
hectares of land in the European Union
last year
Spain was the worst affected country
accounting for 40 percent of the burnt
area
scientists say heat waves caused by
climate change will make wildfires more
likely Barbara and gopa Al Jazeera